معنى من معبر باب الهوى صحفيه محمد الاشقر
محمد اهلا بك معنا انقل لنا الصوره من حيث
انت من معبر باب الهوى الحدودي بين تركيا
وسوريا
نعم يعني في الحقيقه تستمر يستمر دخول
الوافدين من تركيا الى سوريا وفق قرار
الاجازه الذي يسمح بدخول السوريين حاملي
بطاقه الحمايه المؤقته
الصادره عن الولايات التي اصابها الضرر
والتي تدمرت في
تركيا يعني لحد هذه اللحظه اخر رقم اخذناه
من اداره معبر باب الهوى هو 1500 شخص
دخلوا الى هذا المعبر وبعد ان اخذنا هذه
الاحصائيه تم رصدنا دخول خمسه حافلات تقل
المزيد من الاشخاص
السوريين طبعا هناك العديد من التسهيلات
والاجراءات التي تنفذ من قبل الطرفين
الطرف التركي والطرف السوري هنا في سوريا
يعني كما تشاهدون خلفي على تجري الاجراءات
في مكتب الهجره والجوازات ليتم بعدها نقل
هؤلاء المسافرين عبر باصات المعبر الى
محيط مدينه سرمدا ومن هناك يتم استقبال
الوافدين من قبل الاهاليهم ومن ليس لديه
ماوى يعني تعمل يعمل اشخاص من مختلف الفرق
والمنظمات ووزاره التنميه هنا على تامين
ماوى لهم ولو كان مؤقتا نعم طيب محمد يعني
هناك يعني مع مع كوالي الايام بعد الزلزال
برزت هذه يعني الرغبه لدى السوريين الذين
هربوا من سوريا ولجوا الى تركيا طوال
السنوات الماضيه بعد الزلزال هناك من قرر
ان يدفن اقربائه الذين قتلوا في الزلزال
الاوتوفوا في الزلزال داخل بلده في
الاراضي السوريه وهناك من قرر العوده ما
الذي يعني ما الذي نقله اليك من تحدثت
اليهم هناك في المعبر
نعم يعني في الحقيقه يعني اغلب من تحدثنا
اليهم هنا وصفوا لنا المشهد في تركيا بانه
المروع جدا يعني نتيجه الحادثه وهذه وهذا
وهذه الكارثه التي ضربت عده ولايات في
تركيا طبعا اغلب الوافدين الى حد هذه
اللحظه هم من حاملي بطاقه الحمايه المؤقته
في مدينه
انطاكيا احدى الاكبر الولايات التي تضررت
في جنوب تركيا طبعا ان سمحت
لمعلومات اكثر ان استضيف معي السيد مازن
علوش مدير مكتب العلاقات العامه والتنسيق
الاعلامي في معبر باب الهوى استاذ مازن
مرحبا بك بالبدايه ما هي الاجراءات وما هي
التسهيلات للسوريين الذين يودون العوده
الى سوريا طبعا بعد عدد جلسات بيننا وبين
الاخوه في الجانب التركي تم التوصل لاقرار
لاهلنا السوريين اللاجئين في تركيا
والمقيمين في الولايات التي تم الاعلان
انها منكوبه بان ياتوا الى بلدهم سوريا في
زياره حريث ما تهدا الاحوال هناك وتنتهي
حاله الطوارئ طبعا بفضل الله تم اقرار هذه
الاجازه قبل يومين لشاهدنا اليوم صباح
اليوم توهد اهلنا ضمن هذه الاجازه منذ
ساعات الصباح الباكر وحتى الان نحن في
منتصف الليل يستمر التوافق اهلنا في اجازه
الخاصه استثنا
للسوريين مقيمين في الولايات المنكوبه بلغ
عدد الواصلين حتى تاريخ الساعه قرابه 1750
مواطن ربما سينتهي الدخول بعد قليل بحسب
ما بلغنا الان جانب تركي انه لم تبقى
مسافرين على ان يعاد في الصباح الباكر
الساعه الثامنه صباحا استئناف دخولهم
سيستمر الدخول بشكل يومي لا نعلم متى الحد
النهائي اليوم النهائي لايقاف الدخول
الامور تجربه بفضل الله باعلى احسن ما
يرام نحن كنا نقوم باستقبالهم منذ لحظه وص
من البوابه التركيه ننقلهم بحافلات المعبر
الى هنا الى صاله الهجره والجوازات هنا كل
مواطن يقوم بختم اوراقه واخذ الدوري
العوده لتركيا بعد انتهاء الاجازه ومن ثم
نقوم بنقله مباشره الى ساحه مدينه سرمدا
هنالك ايضا الاهالي يقومون بانتظارهم ومن
ليس لديها هذه ايضا خصصنا حافلات لنقلهم
الى اي مدينه يريدونها بالنسبه للسوريين
الذين ليس لديهم احد هنا يقيمون عنده ايضا
الاخوه في وزاره التنميه وضعوا نقطه هنا
في في صاله الهجره
لديهم فريق موجود هنا يقومون بتسجيل اهالي
وايضا نقله مباشره الى مساكن مخصصه لاهلنا
المتضررين من زلزال القادمين من تركيا بان
كي لا يبقى في العراء في في منطقتنا الحمد
لله الامور جيده بفضل الله تعالى
تحدثنا عن عوده السوريين المنكوبين ولكن
ماذا عن عوده الجنازات السوريين ما هي ما
هو العدد الذي وثقت طموح حتى هذه اللحظه
وما هي الاجراءات لدخول
جثامين السوريين القتلى نتيجه هذا الزلزال
طبعا
منذ اول ايام الزلزال في مساء يوم الاثنين
بدات تردنا تباعا جثامين لاهلنا السوريين
الذين قضوا في الزلزال في تركيا
وصلنا على مدار الايام الماضيه وحتى
التاريخ اليوم
جثامين ل 1500 شهيد وصلونا من
معظمها من العائلات عائلات كامله توفيت في
في الزلزال
طريقه نقلهم الى الى المناطقنا طبعا كل
شهيد لديه اقرباء هنا وايضا له يديه معارف
في الطرف التركي يقومون بنقل جنازته الى
مقبره مدينه الريحانيه هنالك قوموا بتسجيل
اسمه ومن ثم تقوم سياره التركيه بنقله الى
بوابتنا من الطرف التركي لدينا نحن هنا
قسم الجنازات التابع لمكتب تنسيق الطبي في
المعبر فريق متكامل موجود على مدار 24
ساعه يقوم باستقبال الجثامين ومن ثم
يقومون بتوثيق الاسماء
ومن ثم نقلها بسياره الجنازات الى البوابه
من الطرف الاخر هنالك يكون اهالي المتوفى
ينتظرون يقوم بنقل جسمانه الى مدنهم
وبلداتهم لايصال الى دفنها هناك اريد ان
انوه ان هذا الرقم هو ليس كل السوريين
الذين توفوا في الزلزال فلدينا مئات
السوريين الذين هم اصولهم تعود الى المدن
التي تحت سيطره النظام هؤلاء كلهم تم
دفنهم في تركيا بالاضافه الى انه ما زالت
مئات او الاف السوريين ما زالوا تحت
الانقاض ربما ستجرد تصلنا جثامنهم تباعا
خلال الايام القادمه هذا بما يخص موضوع
الجثامين الشهداء سؤال اخير استاذ مازن
يعني هناك
يدور حديث حول افتتاح معبر اخر لاستقبال
السوريين الراغبين بالعوده الى سوريا ما
هي المعلومات التي تملكها ما هي المعابر
التي سيتم افتتاحها ومتى سيبدا العوده
سيتمكن السوريون من العوده من خلال هذه
المعهد طبعا الاجازه تم قرارها من عده
معبر
بداوا بمعبر الابيض قبل يومين في منطقه
الذي
يكون على منطقه نبع السلام شمال مدينه
الرقه ومدينه الحسكه
ربما ستفتح ايضا خلال الايام القادمه
الدخول ايضا من معبر جرابلس ومعبر الراعي
ان شاء الله بحسب ما وصلنا اما حتى تاريخ
اللحظه معبر باب الهوى ومعبر تل ابيض
ومعبر الحمام طبعا العدد الاكبر هو معبر
باب الهوى وصلنا اليوم 1750 مواطن
بالمقابل وصل منوره الابيض اليوم 850
مواطن شكرا لك سيد حازم على هذا الوقت
طبعا كما نعم نعم اشكرك شكرا جزيلا
الحقيقه على هذه الصوره الحيه ايضا على
معبر من معبر باب الهوى والشكر موصول
لضيفك ايضا شكرا لك محمد